men should have the right to choose to
be fi to choose not to be fathers sorry
sorry if women have the right to choose
not to be mothers do you think men
should have the right to choose not to
be fine I have that choice anyway
agreed here yeah here they have that
choice
okay so do you do you think that's right
yes or no and why
that a man can sign off on his rights
and not pay child support
and not pay child support on the babies
there yeah because if a girl has the
right to get into attention he have the
right to sign off
do you mean in the circumstances that
says a woman was pregnant and she said
she's keeping it and the guy's saying oh
I don't want the baby do you mean in
that circumstance or you mean in general
like yeah so if um
yeah if if there's a baby and I don't if
I don't want to be a mother I can get an
abortion so he should be able to sign
off on the rights yeah and not have any
kind they'll have to get a contract in
that time where he says I don't want to
be of um the father and you're still
having a child and then I don't think
you should have to pay child support
you're basically saying cool I'm okay
with being a single mom then I think
it's kind of hard to answer that one
because like you said before a woman has
a choice
um to take contraception but so does a
man have a choice to wrap up so he
doesn't get her pregnant so I feel like
you both have a responsibility if you
have an unprotected sex as a man you
know what can happen so
I just think some women they'd get
pregnant like on purpose like to break a
family or whatever so I think in cases
like that she should deal with it and be
responsible at the fact that you've both
done it so he didn't want a kid you know
he didn't want a kid like some women use
it to entrap men so I think she should
deal with it like if it's like that then
he has a right well and we're the only
ones that can consent um and know all of
the circumstances because we know when
we're ovulating and we know if we're at
birth control or not so I mean girls as
she as she was saying I have an IUD yeah
mm-hmm
what do you guys think yes no
yeah I feel like you know
they both have the responsibility and
I don't know I don't really know how I
feel about that
um
I would see you like if it's like a one
night stand
and like certain women their day when I
have a child by whatever they're not
really concerned who their dad is yeah I
think he should be able to have the
freedom to say you know what I'm not
saying it's right here
I'm not saying it's right in the sense
of doing it like the same way of
abortion I think each circumstances is
going to be unique to its own you know
what's interesting we'll call a guy a
deadbeat dad but a girl that has an
abortion isn't a deadbeat mom yeah
I would never call anyone a deadbeat dad
like that so everyone won't say that
because the child isn't here yet whereas
when the child is here and they expect
of Dad to look at that child and see how
beautiful he is and just want to help I
mean but you'd expect a mom to not want
to kill her child but I feel like but
people are visual I realized when a
woman's pregnant well how it depends she
doesn't do it six months you can't see
that baby you can just see a little bump
whereas you can see a little beautiful
little baby sitting before you yeah but
you can get an ultrasound yeah I mean
like and you could feel the beat yeah
you can definitely feel it 100 but I
just feel like
from outside of looking in people will
judge a man more because they think oh
the child is here you're and you're
still not being active I just think as
women we're more judgmental like and
harsh on men in general like I think
women judgment too much and are
ungrateful for certain things and fail
to look at ourselves as women but I feel
like men do judge men as well for
example if there was a person that's a
father and he saw someone else not being
active I mean as individuals like I
think women I think were very selfish
naturally like all we think about is
ourselves and unless you like block out
society and start taking reflection and
thinking about who you are as a person
like I've I've been in like with my
partner like I've mold and moaned and
when you come to the conclusion but you
know what I'm just moaning too much like
give him a break you get it yeah I
disagree females are not selfish
naturally that's not an actual trick I
don't mean I feel like in society now I
think women are very selfish like she's
saying a deadbeat dad I hear so many
women say that and I just think it's so
disrespectful to the child let alone the
man well why is it respectful today
because in a lot of the cases the man is
in a deadbeat dad like so many dads want
to be a dad and they can't be one so
like how is he a dead beat down because
he's not giving you money it's all based
on what I said in the beginning it's all
based on money when I give money for
tourism I'd like to raise a child though
say that I'm sorry it takes money to
raise a child though I don't believe
that it does because like I understand
we've got to survive which is what I say
money is important but like
I think women expectations are far too
high like
they want too much like a household and
a Family Foundation isn't built on money
like we had less years ago and we did
more with families right now
50 pound a week I can survive on 50
pound a week if you have 500 pounds you
know it is I feel like it depends on
what type of lifestyle you want to yeah
as women like I think modern women are
tend to be selfish because they pick a
lifestyle over a family yeah yeah yeah
you're right they would rather have a
certain quality of living rather than
multiple children well I I just think
women are waking up a little bit I
personally feel like women are waking up
and smelling the coffee and realizing we
want more like we want we might be
brainwashed to believe that we should be
that way to be honest I don't think so
like for example I look at my parents
marriage for example and I see so many
flaws in that marriage and I look at my
mum even till this day now you know my
dad passed away three years ago and I
look at my mum and she still complains
about the things that my dad did not do
in that marriage even till this day now
how long am I married oh God like 30
years I think that doesn't even exist
now like it's so rare but I look at
least she's still stuck stuck together
yeah but I look at that and I think to
myself you know what I don't want that
life it's because I want to be with a
man my mom does the same thing she makes
me believe that I deserve better like
you you get your career but that's
because the new modern society there is
nothing wrong with wanting it I think
it's life for yourself I agree I
completely agree absolutely there's
nothing wrong with wanting it but can
you get it yeah
is is if that's true then you'd have it
like women women would have it yeah in
general 50 of women wouldn't be going on
the path of being single and childless
in the future like by 2030 like they
wouldn't be on that path if they could
all get it and so a lot of times like
the especially on like Tick Tock and
[__] I see all these girls that are like
raise your standards raise your
standards like and it's just like yeah
but a lot of those girls aren't going to
get what you're saying
what percent of women get to be
Housewives one in five that means four
don't I think it's something the
majority of you aren't going to get that
yeah but it doesn't just mean that they
want to be Housewives maybe they just
want to live a comfortable life and it's
not about marrying a rich man it's about
marrying a man with a provider average
salary is 41 000 a year and you guys
even said yourself like you how many
people here wanted to pay 20 or less of
the bills but what percent of us are in
the top 20 of women and so the men are
looking up and asking what do they get
out of it they don't get Purity they
don't get you through none of us are
virgins anymore and and they get in the
UK they get a 31 year old wife so she's
on the brink of geriatric pregnancy why
on Earth would they have a provider
mindset for a non-traditional wife
yeah I mean yeah I'm sorry
I mean what I would say to that is
there's like what seven billion men out
there I'm sure you can find the man that
you want as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible